hello and welcome to this video
yeah but this is a bit of a different
video than usual and it's something that
serial of mine pointed out to me and I
think I've seen this before which never
really did remember it there is a
website called ego meter dotnet where
you can serve a couple of chest problems
then they estimate your yellow rating so
I'm going to do it I think it's going to
be fun just look at some positions and
solve them it is 76 positions and I'm
not going to take long I means I'm not
going to look at the position for 10
minutes or so let's see what happens and
have some fun you can go there yourself
you know with the rather I've got the
link in the video so let's see the first
position this is a classic mate and a
couple of moves I never used it as the
first position so a queen yet it's it's
immediately I don't have to import the
sequence of moves ok so now okay I'm in
check here and I have to have to move
the King yeah where do I go I need to go
to f5 yeah to ensure to ensure a
promotion
hmm so this is not a technical one I
guess they want Bishop g1 but that is
actually not so clear you can play queen
you wanted us still better g3 is
probably not so good g3 it takes pawn
takes rook f3 so I'm going to preserve
the vision not sure that's right okay
interesting as again a closed position
I cannot go f4 because of capturing
twice like FY thinks takes takes rook
takes Bishop d6 a move that
strategically would make sense as Bishop
f3 to trade it with Bishop g4 so I'm
going to play that your hip like is
threatening g5 so h4 looks normal
sorry okay funny yeah here Queen g6
looks like an interesting move sorry
I've got a slide a slight cold it seems
Queen g6 if the pawn takes 97 is mating
H takes H takes made so winter sex
I hope that wasn't a mouse look he was
close so Wow
now he looks very tempting to sorry with
white to put the bishop on to see form
if you can get there that would be very
helpful on the other end Black has look
h d8 and roopd - sorry we should have
one rupee eight Bishop c4 Brooke t2 then
rookie - maybe yeah okay oh here white
is under some pressure at first glance
at least the King looks a bit shaky
however black has problems with the back
rank a move that comes to mind is rook
checks a 6b takes risk we take the 8
critics as create made immediately
Queenie a the screen f8 look a 6 I um
there's no no quite reply to that oh
that looks dangerous for black my old
king is safe there's just Queen e1 then
Queen g6 Windsor Queen g6 pawn takes
rook g7 + 96 mate
Oh white to move here
[Music]
we got we got the wrong got the wrong
Bishop okay let me shape G toward Bishop
g2 intending age home okay white two of
him is somewhat active maybe he three
years we have b5 as an active idea
can't be five looks kind of normal I
just wonder if I don't know you know
what that is that is that is Petrosian
the Petroleum exchange sack with reverse
colors rookie three yeah that blockades
everything this is I have seen it that's
the puzzle how to draw this came that
King edge one for them for the for the
district opposition
I definitely have seen this move this is
position yeah I want to calculate ages
in this thing now yeah this is Ella coin
against News ovitch from San Remo 19
something 1930 or so I think this is the
game and I think okay whatever a five is
a good move
it's gained more space Oh white yet you
move the here you got something here
this position that is surprising
look t1 yeah I would play make c5 more
difficult so let's do it
Oh interesting
now g6 I'm prevent prevent rook g8 and
[Music]
96
I think should do the trick yeah
oh that looks funny can I just take on
see 797 Kings e7 King g16 g17 f7 you go
to g8 but then you are going to get
trapped in the corner it's no good
[Music]
hmm don't don't see the win him
okay it's actually you can do this by
excluding excluding options 96 doesn't
work then you only have 97 and
potentially 97 97 Bishop takes King g6
Bishop in the corner king of 7k d 7
injecting air takes King of AIDS down
man
ok
[Music]
[Music]
and ninety-seven King just doesn't work
just doesn't work hmm what am I missing
here I go 96 he takes it pawn takes e5
that's can do sexy for king of Stephen
King g8 that's my father so slow don't
die don't you
but night-night g7 can never be right
yeah there is always ending in the
stalemate some of you you basically have
to take him I don't quite see why it
should work but okay
yeah this is a clear thing I mean there
probably won't be for for the minority
attack but okay
[Music]
let's see that is a game over Anaheim I
don't kind of over something like that
Queenie for I think it's good it's good
anyway I mean despite the fact played it
that looks like there should be some
tactic rook da guia wins material but
shoot the eight Queen yet made and
rocked yet you take the Queen okay now
here it also looks like some tactic he
could could be working however when the
Queen backs Queen does not have many
squares that may also play a role if you
take on f7 King takes it will be three
king of ad no I don't see when they're a
move like if you go it was something
like Bishop d2 it's just before left
you
we should be - before I don't see if
something really great after that
and it's a bit disappointing that looks
really very critical
okay so it says something else entirely
that I might be missing I mean
statistically speaking it makes sense to
simply retreat the bishop just that
there is a knight bieed and another
technically inclined moves I feel like
I'm missing a tactic here
no I have no clue I have absolutely no
clue what they what they expect me to do
him Oh Kim let's do something yeah you
have to get to the critical squares of
thank you one year after the key squares
now what to do here like is threatening
[Music]
nothing and we have made actually a 20-7
and made with tweenager and yeah yeah
okay there are many ways to draw it that
is the cleanest one
hmm okay that I don't think this this
would have a that it probably does not
have a pain technical solution a for
maybe a for Bishop shakes and this is
shaky yeah it's a shaky position
[Music]
and normal like booty move would be
would be simply h4 h5 but I don't think
this is best I can I can imagine that
there is some some sort of design I said
okay a for ya
a phobia takes cuneus riba should be
five move text be fine okay it took me
too long
[Music]
Wow okay no nc5 looks normal
yes if actual you have to you need to
break this open okay looks a lot like
that's a background guess you okay going
to be seven yeah like it's got no count
like will be seven that's just
threatening to take it
it's a funny overload okay now it looks
excellent for white but how do we win
probably by overloading c6 a move like
Bishop before maybe but Queen takes is
six as part of this position just taking
on the six could be an option
you know you can actually simply take
because King takes Queen takes d5 King
takes we should be format that's neat
[Music]
yeah t7 needs to mate
rooty seven bishop takes 27 check king c
18 t xf 8 king b7 check on b8
king a6 queen ahead mate
so men to come
okay rupee six our queen is attacked him
our queen is attacked
[Music]
96 politics I don't see how it continues
and rook takes pawn takes Bishop g6
doesn't doesn't quite do it hmm
[Music]
96 fe6 bishop g6 check king of âge rook
checks insects were Vincent yeah so 96
ok wow that looks wild 25 the way that
is enough
yeah 25 Bishop takes rook takes Bishop
takes so Queen d5 check Bishop takes
Bishop takes if I check win so quick so
let's at least enough Wow rook g7 King
takes bishop takes 5 min so Queen rook
g7 King h8 you can take on h7 rook takes
Bishop e5 so OG 7 wins the house
oh that looks funny
so Bishop takes is drawn all right that
is that is a fortress like just goes to
b8 and it's a draw so I have to take
with the pond okay now I cannot okay I
cannot take the Queen because I'm a tit
I need okay sorry
Queen have eggs it's not working because
book takes yeah I cannot take on a wait
so I need some combinational idea night
to e6
there is Queen takes Knight e4 Knight e4
maybe then 94 he the Queen is hanging
and it and the rook is saying yeah yeah
I think okay now here okay this is this
looks like black is overstretched how
how do we win no look g7 King takes 24
check King h8 Queen h5 yeah the children
yeah okay I don't have the million made
Queen h2
close though black is threatening look a
- we're okay - King takes Queen takes on
a - uncie - and made so I have to take
this into account should not look this
idea
[Music]
if a playbook age 8 check King takes
it's made Bishop takes Queen h1 then I'm
threatening made on age 7 and he cannot
defend it just technically with some
move and if he plays rook a to I take it
and then Queen c2 King a 1 Andrew k8 is
covered by the Queen okay nice if it's
right
okay now this doesn't look like this
doesn't look so much like a technical
thing
okay the pawn is attacked on d4 I don't
see a direct solution
[Music]
and white is better here in many ways
even just by a move like Queen B 3 is
pretty a pretty good advantage I don't
want to trade down if possible
[Music]
simply c3 is also just good intending
g-form
I can play g4 sent them back next
position is completely miserable still
c3 is not a very happy mood Queen B to
that I'm still keeping options Wow I
don't know but it's better here
regardless I don't know
yeah this is a best the state wait
look be true takes it checking on seven
trooper seven winning so we'll be
talking on the seventh would be 83%
winning
so which winter that looks awful Queen
f5 we can just about
black doesn't have a threat bishop eh
could be an idea and it looks looks a
bit slow
oops a bit slow
and I don't don't see something super
convincing it's probably wrong I don't
want to stay at this for for ages yeah I
have to do this first a six and then
break through
okay now how do we how do we draw here
it's funny Bishop g3 this d3 Bishop f2
d2 and losing
[Music]
you have to you have to stay on that III
pawn I guess so that after d3 you can
take I just wonder if if Bishop g5 or
Bishop h6 is better not I wait I wonder
I have a hard time to believe that
Bishop g5 and Bishop age 6 are
substantially different I don't know
okay c6
nice motif okay now here okay look f7
yeah should do the trick 26 for check
that eight
Knight f6 leads to media Knight f6 check
takes Quincy for sugar have sex
checkmate yeah here this is a prepare
this is strategic exercise if you don't
take on this heaven you get the cup of
Blanca Bishop from winter kappa blanka
we should be three terrible I have to
take yeah miss should be three stop
canceling
[Music]
it is a well-known well-known position
[Music]
[Music]
could be something from a boob in
snoring game
I think it's rooty five looks looks
quite logical action okay wow that looks
a bit looks a bit wild
but you had just have Quinn take that
five yeah 496 winning stuff yeah
rookie Warner looks very normal spoiling
castling right on the other hand that
could be stuff with the night on v6 and
we see five but it doesn't doesn't be
too much probably just a check looks
dreadful I'm digging this
[Music]
yeah him he white should be quick
just d5 yeah just if I hope cannot allow
195
[Music]
which is made when and the stage is made
okay would be for him
rookie form for this kind of crossfire
combination yeah looking for it's
completely overloading black
[Music]
instead direct way to win here I mean
rook takes f6 Queen takes d6 check the
Queen checks and that leads nowhere
the bishop is celibate low on squares
and embassy aid request some undefended
we still don't see a clear way to
exploit that
no no don't see I don't see a solution
[Music]
what you can do is create for
threatening look f6 Queen h4 Bishop e2
look f6 Queen f6 d6 yeah maybe this is
the Rakim age 7 made
yeah here king e5 should be right yeah
King if I should draw you have to attack
this and go towards the bomb
why isn't queen h7 mate
okay
[Music]
neither six years almost
I know not have 696 works right now I
have six cannot take with the porn
cannot take with any other piece neither
see ya
see for him but let that protects the
palm the hitters only night before him
otherwise cannot get this Queen takes
age five wins pond textbook h6 made I'm
always kind of skeptical ever see made
in one but that is a maiden one King
edge to him for them opposition that
looks funny
hey I can just take the Queen here huh
Oh is there trickery check check
there is no trick
and I also don't see anything better
just take it wait quit takes we should
before check you know what that's a
three no Queen Queen takes f6 mate there
are many mates in one here
[Music]
okay three I cannot be a way to win this
home you know of course I'm winning
then I mean there's no other way to stop
the porn this is what I was trying to
say okay now what is that I can I just
take it huh what's the deal there are
many like one movers how Bishop takes
here takes Winston wins everything
doesn't exactly start with the when
there are some very simple ones at the
end Bishop takes have six of the
strategic moving from like yeah
and now a four this is number 75 so
we're nearing the end of this it's a
really long video didn't quite expect us
before and Ruby 7i wins the Queen so I'm
curious what I'm scoring okay before we
provide you we have some question yeah I
was taking I have taken it somewhat
seriously how many of the 76 chess
problems did she know of ready okay I
didn't use a computer or database that's
easy
how many did I know I knew some
positions you know 10 20 I'm doing 20
come on what's my impression that
difficulty
very I guess how much fun did you have
it was okay yeah let's give it a six and
let's see what I'm scoring I don't tell
me okay I'm a yes I've got feeder
okay do I have a blitz rating on some
servers yes I don't know come on
let's just come I don't know I'm going
next okay okay let's say no no I don't
have any waiting there next oh my god
these are funny funny things how many
hours per week on average do you spend
playing chess plain plain on average 10
let's say ten how many chess books have
you read in the last two years it's I've
bought a million reading completely
let's say ten how many blitz games have
you played in the last 12 months that is
a lot
yeah probably like two to three thousand
or something how many years have you
played chess seriously thirty how many
tournament games did you play in the
last two years maybe 90 or something 80
how many hours per week on average you
spent playing analyzing with a chess
program or computer hmm 20 to 30
something like that and you're tired of
how many hours approximately to receive
lessons by chess trainer this is easy
roughly zero a little bit more maybe
like 20 or something level of play
probably very skilled and next no show
me so it tells me to 6:10 yeah that's
that's of obviously high they say it's
an interval between two for 31 which is
exactly my rating into a thousand 789
interesting yeah expected to score
relatively high day because those some
of those are knowledge base and then
know quite many positions so it's um
it's kind of I thought it would be
something like that
[Music]
interesting they have a they have a
couple of more here couple of more info
here on the page how they use the item
response theory okay interesting yeah so
I hope you enjoyed it I just wanted to
try this out and I felt if I could try
it out I might as well make a video on
it I hope you enjoyed it thanks for
watching